[Musique]
c'est un passage obligé aux îles de la
madeleine tout le monde le sait mais qui
vient avec des appréhensions
il ya des choses et des gouffres que
c'est encourir parce que ça vaut tous
les boulons
on cherche surtout pour ceux qui
viennent en arrière de moi
[Musique]
c'est un changement majeur qui attend la
petite communauté une transition
énergétique
sur l'archipel où nos yeux sont
constamment sollicités par la beauté des
lieux il ya aussi ce monstre une
centrales thermiques au mazout qui
alimente en électricité l'archipel c'est
la plus grosse au québec la plus
polluante mais changement climatique
oblige hydro québec est forcé de
s'adapter pour les hebdomadaires qui
représente le plus grand des autonomes
d'hydro-québec on a regardé plusieurs
solutions donc on parle de raccordement
qu'on parle de l'éolien du solaire du
gaz naturel la biomasse la centrale au
mazout fait partie d'un de ses 22
réseaux autonomes à elle seule elle
était responsable de 40 pour cent de
toutes les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre produites par hydro québec en 2010
est la solution retenue après
consultation publique un câble
sous-marin de 225 km qui relie la
gaspésie à l'archipel permettant ainsi
de réduire de 94% léger us liés à la
production d'énergie aux îles une option
qui selon hydro québec répond à des
critères importants donc on part de
l'environnement on parle des coûts
l'acceptabilité sociale et de la
fiabilité qui sont les caractères qu'il
y ait de la conversion de nos réseaux
autonomes
la société d'état promet de garder ses
quatre-vingt deux employés entre autres
parce qu'elle a choisi de laisser en
fonction sa centrale thermique une
centaine d'heures par année une roue de
secours en cas de bris est un atout
utile pendant les heures de pointe
effectivement s'engage à préserver le
même niveau d'emploi la façon de sabbath
déployés c'est pas encore statué on va
travailler ça avec les employés avec les
besoins d'hydro-québec on a aussi des
certaines possibilités qui émerge la
pandémie ce manque de précision laisse
les employés comme pascal lapierre
perplexe des inquiétudes au niveau des
emplois au québec a garanti 92 emplois
quelle forme que ça va prendre
puisqu'elle
on voit tu devenez des
métiers qui va passer plus de temps au
bureau ou quoi que ce soit factice il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes qui sur place qui
se faire santé le madelinot craint par
exemple que son fils mécaniciens ne
puisse lui succéder à la centrale parce
que les emplois permanents et bien payés
sont des remparts contre l'exode des
jeunes
tués en gros pour avoir localement ici
c'est ce que ça
cesse a son importance chaque ampoule
des craintes partagées par le maire
jonathan lapierre inquiet de voir les
emplois disparaître sournoisement au fil
des départs c'est inquiétant parce que
une famille de moins osée c'est
peut-être deux enfants de moins dans une
école qui est un ratio très très limite
entre le maintien de l'école ouverte et
la fermeture de l'école et les
changements risquent aussi d'avoir un
impact sur les emplois indirects c'est
tellement beau hein
comme patrice thériault la moitié des
résidents des îles le chou-fleur maison
avec une fournaise l huile une solution
promu à l'époque par hydro-québec pour
compenser les carences de ses centrales
les quelques uns qui devait s'en occuper
à chaque année à chaque année denis
vérifier et nettoyer les choses mettent
à points voulu à un plan bien sûr très
gros sous contractants guinée puis s'est
faite de tous les médias des élus comme
des fournaises ils vont vérifier zorbit
maîtres l'avons les rabroue blida qui
lui est payé par hydro-québec blue car
ça ça va arrêter il y aura plus on
comptera maintenant les options quant
aux cds succès de nombreux élus et les
emplois de perdus ça ça m'inquiète
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
autre conséquence pour patrice la fin de
ce système subventionné se traduira par
une hausse de 30% de sa facture
d'électricité
c'est un système qui est beaucoup moins
coûteux
présentement que ce que ce qui va
ramener
près de la pointe aux loups s'adressent
ces deux géantes
érigées au début de l'été ces éoliennes
comble environ 10 % des besoins
énergétiques des îles un exemple de la
lure qu aurait pu prendre la transition
énergétique sur l'archipel avec un peu
plus d'audace et d'imagination selon le
maire donc on proposa ça plutôt le un
bouquet énergétique donc une mixité de
solution qui aurait pu aurait pu créer
de l'emploi de la richesse des retombées
donc on est à dans l'univers des
possibles c'est une question de vision
c'est une question de volonté aussi pour
nous c'est un rendez vous manqué le
rendez vous manqué et une occasion ratée
de tourner le dos aux énergies fossiles
car avec la solution retenue par
hydro-québec le monstre est là pour
rester
[Musique]